I'd like you to meet my associate fair
movie stuntman champion weight lifter as
you might have noticed throws things out
i don't want think y'all turn around and
go back to miami your stun that huh yeah
any good we gonna go and get informant
yeah what you waiting for the fourth
could you gonna pay me [ __ ] off or finer
meself 250 never quit oh you're a real
tweet [ __ ] aren't you now there was a
problem with pikas or gypsies you do
about it yeah the way back can't really
understand much of what is being said
you Tommy convert a caterer Easter I
knew [ __ ] man Tammy making snow Irish
it's not English oh yeah fair different
kind is for horses you know it's just
well it's just park a [ __ ] me you loser
sergeant I figure you hey kids how big
is he a big man ask for sure hey man
come along the sides of this fella is
your back salir concert are you sent the
signal that's correct sir
then how did you know our reactor
accident was false well that was a guess
but it seemed logical
very well
I present you the ballistic missile
submarine raid October my officers and I
request asylum